[Music]
hey everybody its charlie time to get
hyped up because they're finally making
steven spielberg's
halo live action television series on
the Showtime network so I'll explain
what's going on what they said about the
plot and when you can expect it to drop
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos so this is supposed to enter
production later this year for potential
late 2019 early 2020 release just to be
on the safe side I would plan for 2020
release just because it sounds like
they're trying to outdo Game of Thrones
with the Game of Thrones level budget
which means that it's gonna take them a
little while to get everything together
they haven't even cast it yet but here's
the official news released from 343
industries so I'll just read this today
we announced that we are working with
some incredible talent to bring you an
epic new story experience said in the
Halo universe the halo TV series the
Showtime network brings its powerful
legacy of experience in building stories
for premium cable and together with
Amblin television and legendary
storyteller Steven Spielberg have been
gracious partners in helping put
together the right creative team to
bring halo to television we are thrilled
to have experienced showrunner Kyle
killin so he were gonna be the
showrunner for the new TV series and
blockbuster director Rupert Wyatt from
the Planet of the Apes series on board
both of whom bring their own flavor of
vision intelligence and voice to halo we
couldn't have asked for a stronger more
passionate team to collaborate with
their estimate is as they'll be in full
production by early 2019 which is why
I'm saying you know about a year
turnaround we probably won't actually
see episodes till 2020 makes me
questions I know everybody wants to know
is is what's the story going to be
when's it going to be set during the
timeline and who are the actors that
they're going to cast so like you
remember I put a clip of halo nightfall
at the beginning of this that was Mike
Colter aka Luke Cage perhaps you'd
rather be a Spartan she should be no
other
you know he used to be a spark
decade ago maybe named Randall zero
three seven one day he up and walks away
and no one walks away from the Spartan
program it's not supposed to be possible
they have too much invested in you fast
for ten years and suddenly I'm looking
at your colonel scarcely it took a bunch
of titanium out of his body imagine a
really big ten episode version of that I
don't think that this halo TV series
will follow Master Chief or any of the
main characters it'll probably involve
characters from the games but it's not
like a Babylon 5 or a game of Thrones
situation where they're directly
adapting novels I think they want to do
something that the fans of the videogame
series will love but that also people
that are big fans of huge sci-fi series
like this or fans of that don't
necessarily play the video game usually
when they try to do really faithful
adaptations to videogame series it just
winds up in disappointment so I'm
totally okay if they don't do all the
main characters the videogame series
they don't do Master Chief as long as
what they do end up doing is really
badass way back when Steven Spielberg
became attached to the project in 2013
people were like oh wow big Band of
Brothers Pacific series set in outer
space with the Halo characters sounds
awesome you know human covenant war or
if they want to do reclaimer saga could
still totally be awesome originally that
halo nightfall series was meant to
bridge the gap between halo fall and
guardians that takes place towards the
beginning of the reclaimer saga but
trades on a lot of events from the first
trilogy of games which was the human
covenant war if you haven't been
following this series for a long time
the original Halo TV series was meant to
be set during the human covenant war
even though it was meant to connect to
halo nightfall and by that time in the
game series around halo 5 we were in the
middle of the reclaimer saga so the
games had already moved past the human
covenant war but they assigned Steven
Spielberg to the project they were
lining people up to direct it it was
originally set up under Microsoft
Studios which is sort of this big TV
movie studio that was going to produce
all this original content for the Xbox
platform around that time but that
started to fall through as they found
out that there really wasn't a market
for it because the amount of money that
they were spending on it like Game of
Thrones hundred plus million dollars per
season which is way more than Microsoft
was ready to throw into this
so the deal started to collapse as time
went on so that's why you find it
hitting a premium cable network like
Showtime now it's gonna be co-produced
with CBS Studios I think they're gonna
distribute it internationally but we'll
see if they have any weird Xbox
distribution plans down the road but I
would worry too much about that stuff
right now like I said you know people
really want it they'll find a way to
watch it what I'm hoping that they do is
that they do go full band of brothers
but they do it in a very Babylon 5
shadow war type of way so if you're not
a big fan of the Showtime network or any
of the big sci-fi series they've done it
like Stargate in the past they've
actually done really good sci-fi but the
mythology of the Halo series is very
similar to the mythology of the Babylon
5 series where you have an ancient race
of beings the first ones in the case of
Babylon 5 that sort of split off because
they have warring interests over what
the future of the universe should be
then many eons later you have lesser
races like humans or the races of the
Covenant to sort of discover these
ancient cultures and artifacts and treat
them in different ways while at the same
time these ancient races start to
influence them and push them in the
direction they think that they should go
so on one level you have that Band of
Brothers aspect where you just have a
bunch of people trying to survive in
this grand galactic war but then you
have this epic mythology behind it
pushing this overarching story in the
case of Babylon 5 that was the shadow
wars in the case of halo right now we're
in the middle of the reclaimer saga so
I'm hoping that they treat the series in
a very Babylon 5 way or if you're a big
deep space 9 fan the Dominion War where
you have a bunch of lesser races that
are warring with each other over control
of the universe but you also have the
wormhole aliens so it's a really cool
blend of war drama action and high
concept mythology but just let me know
in the comments what do you want them to
do with this TV series which characters
do you want them to do and which part of
the timeline do you want them to covered
do you want it to be set closer to
present day like we're getting ready for
Halo Infinite do you want to be set
during the past and focus more on the
human covenant war probably the biggest
challenge to this and it's not that big
of a challenge for people that really
like Halo and want this halo TV series
is the fact that not that many people
get the Showtime network like Showtime
series typically draw a fraction of the
audience that HBO series do so it would
be really hard for a Showtime
TV show to pull Game of Thrones level
viewership numbers but I think if they
do a really good job with it and people
really want this TV series they'll find
a way to watch it so I don't think it's
too much of a problem but you have a lot
of really awesome premium cable shows
that nobody watches just because they're
on channels that people don't want to
pay for so it does become a bit of a
consideration but we'll probably learn
more about that next year if they get
started early enough they might be done
filming in time to get a comic-con
trailer out for comic-con 2019 but
obviously I wouldn't expect to see any
new footage from it for a long long time
just let me know what are all your
reactions in the comments what'll happen
is is I'll do video updates on it as we
get new information we also just learned
about the first episode of Titans so
I'll do a video about that sometime
tomorrow obviously new Game of Thrones
coming up will you wait for everything
click here for my new Avengers 4 video
and click here to learn all about that
new DC comics streaming service thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight